GILBERT STRANG: OK,
in this second part,
I'm going to start with linear
equations, A times x equal b.
And you see actually, the
first real good starting point
is A times x equals 0.
So are there any solutions to
the matrix, any combinations
of the columns that
give 0, any solutions
to A times x equals 0?
Now, I'm multiplying a matrix
A by a vector x in a way
you'll know.
I take rows of x times,
it's called a dot product.
Rows of A times x.
So I have a row of numbers.
And x is a column of numbers.
I multiply those numbers and
add to get the dot product.
And I'm wondering,
can I get 0 for each?
Is every row-- so
having a 0 there
is telling me, in geometry,
that that row is perpendicular,
orthogonal to that column.
If a row dot product
with a column
gives me a 0, then in
n dimensional space,
that row is perpendicular, 90
degree angle to that column x.
So I'm looking to see,
are there any vectors x
that are perpendicular
to all the rows?
That's what Ax equals
0 is asking for.
Oh, and that's what I've
just said right there.
I've used the word orthogonal.
That's more of a high level
word than perpendicular.
So I'll stay with that.
It sounds a little cooler.
OK.
And now, we can also
look at that transpose.
Oh, do you know what the
transpose of a matrix is?
I take those rows
and flip the matrix,
so that those rows
become the columns.
And the columns of A become
the rows of A transpose.
So I'll look at A
transpose times--
we'll call it y for
the new problem.
A transpose y is all 0s.
And then the null space will
be any vector, any solutions,
any y that's perpendicular
to the rows of A transpose.
So I would need couple of hours
of teaching to develop this
properly because
we're talking here
about the fundamental theorem of
linear algebra, which tells me
that the vectors
in the null space,
like that, are perpendicular
to the vectors.
These guys are.
That's the row space.
Oh, but maybe I have told you.
We've said that, from this
equation, that tells you
the geometry that
that row vectors are
perpendicular to the x vector,
the thing in the null space.
So x is there.
The rows are there.
And they're perpendicular.
Now, if I transpose
the matrix, remember
that means exchanging
rows and columns,
so I have a new
matrix, new size even.
It will the same--
but it's a matrix.
The same will be true for it.
The rows become the columns.
And the solutions to the new
equation with A transpose
go in that space.
So then that little
perpendicular sign
is reminding us of the geometry.
So rows perpendicular
to the x's.
Columns perpendicular
to the y's.
That's the best.
I finally saw the
right way to say that.
So I have two pairs.
And I know how big each
of those four things are.
Those are the four fundamental
subspaces, two null spaces,
two solution spaces with 0.
Null means 0.
So these x's are in the null
space because of that 0.
Those are the n's.
And then this is the column
space and the row space.
So we've got four spaces
altogether, two pairs.
And now, you get to
see the big picture
of linear algebra, where the
four fundamental subspaces do
their thing.
There you go.
You can die happy now.
The row spaces there, those
are rows of the matrix,
independent rows of the matrix.
That's why I don't
put in all the rows.
There are m rows.
But I only put in
independent ones.
So that might be a smaller
number r, r the rank.
And here are the solutions,
the guys perpendicular to them.
This is the rows of the matrix.
These are the vectors
perpendicular to it.
These are the columns
of the matrix.
These are the vectors
perpendicular to the columns.
You see it's just
a natural splitting
of the whole spaces of vectors
into two pieces and two pieces.
And I think of the matrix A,
when it multiplies stuff there,
it gives stuff here.
When A multiplies
a vector x, you
get a combination
of the columns.
That with the very,
very first slide.
A times x is a combination
of the columns.
And then we look at
some x's, if there are
any, where A times x gives 0.
And there's 0 right there.
OK.
OK, so that's the big picture.
And I'll just point to
another little point
that's hiding in this picture.
You see that little symbol
there, that little thing,
and it's also here?
What that means is
that those guys are
perpendicular to these.
And these are
So we have four subspaces, two
pairs, two perpendicular pairs.
And that's when you get the
idea of knowing what they mean,
knowing how to find them,
at least for a small matrix,
you've got the heart of
linear algebra part one.
This is the first half
of linear algebra.
OK, I'll just see
what else there is.
Oh, here, oh, well,
this is another comment.
I've hardly told you how
to multiply two matrices.
The usual way is
rows times columns.
But linear algebra being
always interesting,
there's another
way that I happen
to like, columns times rows.
Now, there is a
column times a row.
Now, column times a row,
we've seen that once
for that rank one matrix.
Do you remember I said
that those rank one
matrix, one column times is one
row are the building blocks?
Well, here is the building.
Those are n of those blocks.
A column times a row,
a column times a row.
And here is a reminder of the--
oh, we've only--
oh, we're coming up
to A equal LU, the first one.
Get on with it,
Professor Strang.
OK.
OK, now we're solving equations.
Now we're going to get
L times U. So right.
So there's two equations and two
unknowns solved in high school
and how.
Do you remember how?
That's the whole point.
If I take twice that equation,
so it's 4x plus 6y equal 14,
and subtract from
this one, then I
get an easy equation
for only y by itself.
So that's what I did.
That's called elimination.
I eliminated this 4x.
It's gone.
It's 2 times that.
That's why I chose
to multiply it by 2.
Then 2 times this
gives me 4 x's.
When I subtract it, it's gone
and I'm left with 1y equal 1.
So I know the answer y equal 1.
And then I go backwards to
x equal 2 because 2x plus,
this is now, 3 equals 7.
2x is 4.
x is 2.
And the real point
about linear algebra
done right is that
all those steps
can be expressed as a
break up, another way
to break up the matrix A into
a lower triangular matrix.
You see that that
matrix is triangular.
It's lower triangular.
And this one is
upper triangular.
So those are called
L and U. Yeah, yeah.
So what we did here is expressed
by that matrix multiplication.
You really want to express
everything, in the end,
as multiplying a
couple of matrices.
Then you know exactly
where you are.
So that's the idea
of elimination.
And now, we only were
doing a 2 by 2 matrix.
You remember our little matrix
was pathetic, 2, 3, 4, 7.
That was our matrix A.
We can't stop there.
So linear algebra goes
on to matrix of any size.
And this is the way
to find the triangular
factor L and the upper
triangular factor
U. That would need more time.
So all I want to say is,
when you're doing elimination
solving equations, then
in the back of your mind
or in the back page, you are
producing an L matrix lower
and a U matrix upper.
So yeah.
Let me see.
Yeah, here we see them.
The L matrix is all 0s above.
The U matrix is all 0s below.
And that's what is
really happening.
So that's what computer
system totally focuses on.
OK, that's the first
slide of a new part.
So I'll stop here and coming
back to orthogonal vectors.
Good.